はい　どうもー
ペヤングやきそばが
販売中止になりました。
あの、僕ですね
販売中止になる少し、一週間ぐらい前に
ペヤングを集めたんすよ！
個人的に
全然、中止になるとかしらなくて
純粋に一ファンとして集めたんすよ！
たぶんね、ちょいちょい足りないのがあると思うんですけども
一応、手に入る分の全種類のペヤングを手に入れました！
パチパチパチパチ！
ま）見たことないもん！
ないでしょ！
まずは普通のノーマルペヤングです
これはみんな知ってると思います
６）ガーリック醤油焼きそば
ま）ハーフ＆ハーフのカレー
焼きそばの麦そばです！
６）Youtuber御用達の激辛焼きそば
６）痛っ！
ま）焼きそば極み
ペヤング海老そばです！
６）焼き蕎麦ねぎ塩風味
痛っ！
ま）もんじゃ風味
結構、リアルなほうでたぶんだいぶ珍しいペヤングなんですけど
2人が遊びに来てるんで
今日はこのペヤングのほんとに頂点に君臨するような
みんなで食べようと思って
もう、全種類混ぜます！
結局、一番おいしいのは混ぜれるんだよ
そう思う
全）ははははは
今日はみんなでね
ぺヤングをもう混ぜて、食って
ま）楽しむ、、楽しもう！
じゃあ
作りましょう！みんなで
ま）いきましょう！
６）よし！
よしＯＫ！
わっ！
ま）はははははは！
びっくりした！
全部一応、箱から出して
ソースはあとでまとめてぶち込みます！
あっ！
ばかっ！
こたつだろ！
ま）ははははは！
なにしてんだよ！おまえ
お湯入れていきます！
ま）はい！
ま）あっ！
あー！
あーー！
あーーーー！
こっち側だけ先に3分たったんで湯切りします
かけてほしい？！
６）かけてほしい[ドＭ]
ま）はははははは！
はい
６）あつっ！[ドＭ]
ま）よっしゃいこう！
はい！というわけでなんとかできました！
おめでとうございます！
ま）かんぱーい！
６,は）かんぱーい！
ま）あっ！辛い
激辛のほうだ！
なんともいえねぇわ
なんか、なんとも言えない
ま）辛い
辛い？！
そっちは？
６）ふつうにおいしい
ふつうにおいしい！
場所によって全然味が違うんすよね
だけどたぶんこっからは
味どうこうより食べるか食べないかの戦いになります
うまいんだけどね！
ま）なになになになに
ちょっと待って！
もうちょっと食べさせて！
ま）はぁ？！
冷凍庫
ま）なんか増えてね？！
ま）入れたろ！
ま）おまえ入れたろ
ちょっとだけ
ま）はじめが冷凍庫入れに行ってた時俺も入れたから
なにしてたん！！
全）ははははは
６）俺、どっちも知ってたから
６）よし！
いけっ！
６）いくぞー！
ラストです
（拍手）
よし、完食です！
ま）やったー！！
まぁ、おいしかったしょ
最初だけみたいな
最初だけおいしかった
やっぱ量てきな問題がありましたね
というわけで、完食でございます！
というわけで我々は
いち早くぺヤングの復活を心よりお待ちしてます！
よろしくおねがいします！
ま）ごちそうさまでした！
関連動画　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　【大量】ペヤングやきそばを10Kg食う！
オススメ動画　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　【髪色】マニックパニック14種類混ぜたらこうなった・・・